brought to you by far cry primal rise
above extinction in stores februari 23rd
hey guys it is Friday once again which
means it's time to fill you in on this
week's the biggest stories in gaming
indie gaming group home studios are
remaking that was nice of the ultra
public the team does hold the reboot of
heroin and intend to bring the popular
RPG to life again in Unreal Engine 4
they're also creating new missions and
wells in addition to allowing players to
switch to first-person view the team is
insisting that while it's not legal for
them to sell the game it is illegal for
them to make it so the remake will be
free when it releases you can see the
studio live streaming their development
on twitch and check out a bunch of
screens from the remake in our story on
game [ __ ] Ubisoft cos gamma has said
that they are rethinking Assassin's
Creed's release strategy speaking at a
recent investor day the CEO emphasized
that giving the team the time they need
to release something exceptional is the
publishers priority and that they would
not be committing to the yearly cycle
that's held up since assassin's creed
two cameras that releases would be
regular but they wouldn't commit to a
yearly or by yearly cycle the company
previously explains the decision would
allow its developers to make better use
of money technology and the current
rumor is that the next game may be set
in egypt this week microsoft announced
backwards compatibility support for dark
souls and revealed that is going to be a
pre-order bonus for dark souls 3 and
xbox watch the info leaked prior to
Microsoft's announcement on to the
australian xbox marketplace was spotted
by reddit users and was later officially
confirmed the original dark souls will
be available for free with digital
pre-orders of Dark Souls 3 on Microsoft
songs but his offer is only available
for a limited time it's also unclear
whether this bonus copy of the game
includes the DLC Dark Souls 3 launches
on April 12 on pc xbox one and ps4 next
up Sega has been giving away free games
on Steam this week the publisher are
currently holding a sting fail called
make war not love 3 where games like
total war atilla and company of yours
too can be had for cheap but if you'd
really rather pay nothing at all you can
still grab yourself some Sega goodness
earlier this week Sega was offering up
jet set radio hell yeah wrath of the
dead rabbits and golden axe for free as
well as some of the DLC those games were
replaced by three new free games Binary
Domain condemned criminal origins and
streets of rage 2 more free games are
also on their way so keep an eye out
finally 344 explosions are on the
horizon and bethesda reckons the dlc
lineup since part 4 is so good they're
upping the season pass price by 20 bucks
March will bring this hand Allah or Tama
Tron DLC which calls for you to kill off
evil robots and make your own after that
wasteland workshop is arriving in April
to let you track different creatures
other than fight and making new changes
to your settlements finally in May you
can get your hands on the $25 bar harbor
where you'll be chasing down a mystery
woman and uncovering a secret colony of
sense but there's also announced to that
come March one you'll need to pay fifty
dollars if you want to grab the deal see
pass instead of the original thirty
dollars but people who've already bought
the season plans and won't have to fork
out anymore but those are also clarified
that there are several more unannounced
expansion packs plans let me know what
you cared about this week in that
comment box below this week on site Lucy
chats about how far cry primal is
different from the other games in the
franchise and I explore the best things
you can do in the game that is it for me
this week as always be sure to have
yourselves a great weekend a Democrat
and on Monday